PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
you've built your machine
learning models,
and now it's time
to take them to production.
What do you need to do?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and today, we're
going to talk about managing
production machine learning
pipelines.
As you've seen through
[? years ?] of AI Adventures,
machine learning is
a lot of fun and is
much more than just a novelty.
Machine learning models power so
many technologies in our lives,
and there are plenty of new
and better models just waiting
to be applied to the real world.
So how do you transition
from experimenting
with a model to actually
moving it to production?
Well, just as you need
a quality CI/CD pipeline
to maintain a robust
code base at scale,
you need a machine
learning pipeline
to help you monitor,
transform, evaluate,
and serve your
models in production.
What are the different
steps involved
in a machine learning workflow?
Well, first, you ingest the
input data set and split it
for training,
evaluation, and testing.
Then, validate it.
Identify and remove
anomalies from that data,
or handle redundant
features and empty values.
You might have to address
the detected issues,
maybe finding more training
data for certain categories.
Then, you do feature engineering
to transform the data
and enrich the
features to improve
your training, at which
point the model is
ready to train and tune.
Once trained, evaluate
the model to make
sure it generalizes well
enough to use in production.
When the model gets
the green light,
you push it to production.
This production
environment needs
to be powerful enough to support
the rate of inference required
by your application.
Now, when does this ML
workflow become a pipeline?
Well, it will be automated,
and the automation
is necessary, especially
if we want to deploy
these models in production.
So the question now
becomes, how do we
automate the machine
learning workflow tasks
to create an end-to-end
pipeline for deploying
our models into production?
Here is a very high level
architecture of how it works.
TensorFlow is running on
TFX, which in turn is running
inside Kubeflow
pipelines, and that's
running on GKE, leveraging
the Google Cloud Services.
You can create pipelines
with similar functionality
using both Kubeflow pipelines
and TensorFlow extended SDKs.
We have an entire
series on Kubeflow,
which I have linked below.
In this video, let's
focus on TensorFlow
extended, or TFX, which
is an open source,
end-to-end platform
specifically designed
for scalable, high performance,
machine learning tasks.
Here's how it works.
A TFX pipeline is a sequence of
components implementing the ML
workflow tasks,
and they are built
using open source
TFX libraries, which
can also be used individually.
This is sort of a canonical
TFX effect pipeline.
You can think of it as
hello world pipeline.
These orange components come
out of the box with TensorFlow
extended, but you can create
your own components as well.
Once the model is
ready, you deploy it
into a serving cluster
in TensorFlow serving,
TensorFlow.js, TensorFlow
Lite, TensorFlow Hub, or even
AI platform predictions.
Now, what is a TFX component?
It is essentially a task that we
perform in our machine learning
pipeline.
It has a config, and it takes
input from the metadata,
except for the very
first component
which is ingesting the data set
from the original data source.
It takes those inputs using an
input channel, does its task,
and generates the
output artifact
and then uses the output
channel to put those back
into the metadata, and
that's how components
communicate with each other.
The upstream components
will produce an artifact
that the downstream
component depends on,
and the data flows
through the pipeline
by flowing through these
dependencies in the metadata.
Now, what is metadata?
Well, it allows us to trace the
lineage of the artifacts that
are produced, for example, what
data is the model trained with?
Metadata can also be used to
compare previous training runs.
It also allows
tracking and reuse
of previously
computed outputs which
saves quite a bit of time,
especially for larger data
sets and models.
If the input to the
component has not changed,
we don't want to
rerun the component.
We should just be able to pull
the last result from the cache
and reuse it.
Now, let's go back to
our standard components
and understand them
a little bit more.
First, off, ExampleGen helps us
ingest our data from CSV files,
BigQuery, Presto, et cetera.
It splits the data and saves
it off as TF examples and TF
record files.
StatisticsGen will make a
full pass over that data
and calculate
statistics about it.
That's important to understand
our data, if it is new
and if it has changed over time.
SchemaGen then
determines the schema
across our data, such as what
are the types of our features,
and for the
categorical variables,
what are the valid categories?
Example Validator takes both
of those results and looks
for problems, things
like the examples
that have the wrong type
in the particular feature
or a categorical value
that should not be there.
Transform is where the
feature engineering is done.
It will convert the
feature engineering
that we want to do with a graph
that becomes part of our model.
Trainer takes that
graph and the model
that we have defined
using TensorFlow
and trains that model.
Evaluator takes
that trained model
and does a deep analysis of
the performance of that model.
It looks at not just the
entire data set but also
the individual slices
of a data to try
to understand how performance
varies across different parts
of our data.
It can be used for
fairness analysis,
like seeing if your model
is performing differently
for different types
of model users.
InfraValidator makes
sure that we can actually
deploy our model to our
serving infrastructure.
If both Evaluator
and InfraValidator
agree that, yes, we
can deploy our model,
our Evaluator has
checked to make sure
that the model is actually
better than what we have
in production, then
the Pusher will push it
to one of our
deployment targets.
So that was a quick overview
of TensorFlow Extended which
helps us engineer our
machine learning pipelines,
so we can deploy our
models in production.
In the next episode, we will see
TFX and [INAUDIBLE] pipelines
in action in cloud AI
platform pipelines.
Until then, I would love
to hear the topics that
will help you get better
at machine learning and AI.
Drop them in the
comments below, and don't
forget to like and subscribe.